now I'm often asked here on the air
about reverse mortgages and 100% of the
time I've told people to not do reverse
mortgages good article in The Washington
Post over the weekend and I tweeted out
the link over the weekend a guy tweeted
it to me actually is where I found it
and I sent it back out and listen to
this as she was getting on in years her
resources dwindled Virginia Rayford took
out a special kind of mortgage in 2008
that she hoped would help her stay in
her three-bedroom Washington row house
for the rest of her life
Rayford 92 took advantage of a federally
insured loan called a reverse mortgage
that allows cash-strapped seniors to
borrow against the equity in their house
that has built up over decades but the
risks of the financial arrangement are
stark and today the frail widow finds
herself facing foreclosure under the
terms of the loan Rayford can defer
paying back her mortgage debt that
totals about four hundred and sixteen
thousand until she dies sells or moves
out she is however responsible for
keeping up with the other charges namely
the taxes and insurance on the property
the loan servicer Nationstar Mortgage
says Rayford owes six thousand and four
dollars in unpaid taxes and insurance
and if she cannot come up with it she
stands to lose her home in Washington's
Petworth neighborhood I've cried a
million nights wondering about what I'm
gonna do Rayford again she's 92 years
old said across the nation an increasing
number of seniors are facing foreclosure
after taking out reverse mortgages
either because they fell behind on
property charges or failed to meet other
requirements of the complex mortgage
loans according to the federal data and
interviews with consumer and housing
specialists the Federal Department of
Housing and Urban Development HUD which
ensures most reverse mortgages in the
country says it lacks details on the
data detailed data on how many
homeowners have lost their homes or
facing foreclosure in the program by the
way is a lie they don't lack details on
it which was launched in 1989 and covers
about six hundred and thirty six
thousand loans and Nationstar the lender
on this case declined for comment
but a HUD report issued HUD who doesn't
have detailed data issued a report that
found that nearly 90,000 reverse
mortgages held by seniors were at least
12 months behind in payment and taxes
and insurance were expected to end in
quote involuntary termination I don't
think I want to be involuntarily that's
correct that's that's federal
bureaucrats speak for we're gonna shoot
you in the face
involuntary termination oh my god that's
a scary phrase Oh in 2017 that's more
than double of the year before well let
me help you of this folks okay let me
walk you through some numbers there's
six hundred thirty six thousand of these
loans out there ninety thousand of them
are in default headed to foreclosure
that's 14 percent of the loans are
failing that's Astra Freakonomics out
right still he said reverse mortgages
are a critical resource for seniors who
wish to access their accumulated home
equity and age in place thank you for
the HUD spokesman for figuring this out
they have a completely failed loan
program that is causing senior adults to
lose their homes at an unbelievable
record but his answer is it's a critical
resource for seniors who wish to access
their accumulated home equity and age in
place you sound like a lobbyist dude you
know sound like somebody that can add
before 2015 the only thing homeowners
age is 62 and older needed to qualify
for a reverse mortgage was equity in
their home lenders weren't required to
determine whether they could afford to
maintain their homes or cover the taxes
and insurance payments in the future
since homeowners used the funds to pay
off the original mortgages or ran out of
money after covering living expenses
over many years now HUD requires all
borrowers to undergo a financial
assessment Wow before we give a mortgage
we actually do a financial assessment
guys are rocket scientists unbelievable
listen to this tens of thousands of
troubled loans remain more than eighteen
percent
of reverse mortgage loans remember where
earlier figure was 14 currently more
than 18 percent of reverse mortgage
loans taken out from oh 9 to 2016 are
expected to go into default because of
its 1 in 5 because of unpaid taxes and
insurance according to a HUD report that
compares with less than 3% of federally
insured loans in the traditional
mortgage market so your typical FHA loan
about 3 percent of them go bad 18
percent of these reverse mortgages are
going bad I told you these things sucked
representatives of the National reverse
mortgage lenders Association decline for
comment well I would run for the hills
and hide behind the biggest Bush I could
find advocates of the loan including
celebrity spokesman such as Tom Selleck
and Henry Winkler say reverse mortgages
can help seniors enjoy their later years
no they don't really say that they read
a script borrowers can receive listen
there's the terms of reverse mortgage in
case you didn't them borrowers can
receive 50% to 66 percent of the value
of their equity depending on their age
and interest rate and the interest rate
generally set about 5% now why do I tell
you not to get reverse mortgages because
you're gonna lose your home potentially
because you get into all kinds of
problems and because the interest rates
and the fees are a really bad ripoff you
ever heard me say that before
ok so let's hear what they just said
interest rates are generally set about
5% you know what the going rate on a
15-year fixed is today a traditional
mortgage a HUD mortgage do you think
it's do you think it's 5% anybody
anybody out there you think it's 5% I
get a report every morning I'll tell you
what it was this morning 3 and 1/8 so
you're paying almost double you old
people that are getting ripped off thank
you Tom Selleck and Henry Winkler
we appreciate your endorsement you have
the opportunity to pay double and
potentially lose your house when you're
92 this is a dadgum mask people
unbelievable for example the a 73 year
old with a home worth a hundred thousand
and no current mortgage could receive a
loan or a lump sum on monthly
installments up to a line of credit for
up to
fifty-seven thousand nine hundred
dollars not including closing costs
according to HUD so you can take your
$100,000 house and get sixty grand out
of it and potentially lose it it's
anybody listening to this unbelievable
the federal consumer finance Protection
Bureau has long warned about deceptive
advertising and reverse mortgages in
December the federal agency fined three
companies American advisers Group
reverse mortgage solutions and Aegean
Financial for alleged false claim saying
they told seniors with reverse mortgages
that they would not have to make monthly
payments or face foreclosure omitting
the risks of failing to pay property
charges these companies tricked
consumers into believing they could not
lose their homes with a reverse mortgage
said the bureau director the companies
did not admit wrongdoing in settlements
that required that they pay seven
hundred and ninety thousand dollars in
fees one of the companies was American
advisers group which is where Tom
Selleck says he speaks on behalf of them
many older Americans are in a tough spot
right now why not use a reverse mortgage
to make sure you completely lose your
home oh no that wasn't what he said I
put words in his mouth excuse me
hey guys telling you for years reverse
mortgages suck there's all your details
interest rates are double the
foreclosure rates are Eightfold this is
ridiculous answers the question run this
is the Dave Ramsey show